foreign
[Music]
I was flipping through the slides
yesterday
and I was reflecting on the deck would
have been so different if it was
prepared literally just 10 months ago
and the Jenner Revolution that we've all
been part of has really just transformed
our product portfolio your expectations
and where the industry is headed
um but one thing that actually has not
changed uh you know five years ago when
I actually co-founded contact center AI
we we were very sure about this industry
because we knew this would be the first
adopter of AI and you know contact
center was ripe for that and we've seen
that layout over five years and even
with all the Gen AI it was I think one
thing that everyone agrees with is that
contact center is literally the single
biggest use case or at least the first
use case that will come to market with
the Virginia Solutions I think we can
all give ourselves a round of applause
for that uh for being literally
um so we have
um we have a packed session today we'll
try to squeeze out time for Q a at the
end but if we don't manage to do that
you can always catch us at the booth
downstairs
um so I'm shantanu I'm a group product
manager with our contact center AI team
um I have with me Mina my colleague who
leads go to market solution for for all
of ccai and Beyond we have with us two
customers who are going to be talking
about their Journey with Google we have
Alex from gen digital who's going to be
talking about being an early adopter of
CCI platform and how now they're
doubling down on Google and swarup from
Wells Fargo is going to be talking about
the Fargo Journey which was you know a
conversational AI solution that they
developed with Google
um
so we're going to be covering a lot of
topics
um
as I said you know we have a packed
agenda but we'll try to squeeze in
sometime towards the end for Q a as well
um if you think about contact centers
the the pain points are basically the
same as we have seen over the years
which is users are frustrated uh they
don't want to wait in Long queues uh we
have huge agent turnover you know 30 40
percent of the agents quit their job in
the first year itself so we have huge
onboarding time and we need to sort of
empower the agent to handle complex
questions
um and then you have contact centered
operations which is trying to sort of
Juggle these different hats you know
trying to increase Revenue while also
lowering cost and designing this
customer experience just takes months
and quarters so all those problems like
if you're able to present this slide
three years ago it'll basically be
similar problems but I think what has
changed is
the expectations
um is the expectation that an end user
has when it reaches out to a business
because end users are now used to tools
like Bard and other tools in the market
where they can get these gen AI powered
answers very quickly so they are not
they don't they have very little empathy
when businesses put them on hold for 10
minutes or struggle to find an answer to
a question which is very very easy
and also what I have observed over the
last few months is that organizations
expectations have changed as well like
we would go into again with the customer
and we'll try to sort of create a
conversational AI solution and it was
totally okay for us to spend six months
doing that but that's no longer the case
um we want solutions to start adding
value day one onwards and you know
organizations expect Google you know
another providers to be able to match
that expectation
so when we think of ccai you know we
really think of that in sort of in terms
of four broad pillars
um our approach is AI first and it has
been that since day one
um and you know in some ways these
products are arranged in sort of uh
order of you know when they actually
launched but also in terms of the user
Journey you know you typically get
started off with a virtual agent which
is powered by dialog flow uh you know
dialogue is is a solution that's been GA
for for five plus years
um for each of these Solutions we're
going to be talking about how we are
creating the Next Generation version of
that powered by llm
um
after dialogflow you know the call gets
escalated to a human agent you have
agent assist which is a suite of tools
which helps the agent answer the
question better and you can imagine if
the virtual agent is doing its job
really really well it's really the tough
questions that end up with the live
agents and they really need to be
empowered to handle those questions
um with CCI insights which is our third
pillar
what we're really trying to do is make
sense of you know the dark data that
exists in your contact centers which is
not being used to take business
decisions today
um and we believe with you know
uploading audio or transcripts using our
transcription tools to do that and then
trying to make sense of that data can
unlock a lot of value for businesses and
we have already seen that happening in
multiple customers with CCI insights and
finally CCI platform which we launched
last year which is our ccast solution
and the whole idea behind CCI platform
was you know we had these great AI
services but our customers were
struggling with integrating it with
their existing solutions they used to be
long lead times and really wanted to
create an AI first
ccas solution where AI is not enough to
thought we're getting access to Google
solution is literally a click of a
button and we have seen huge success
with CCI platform and we we have gen
digital is going to be talking more
about it in a moment
as you know and I think as Thomas curing
and Sunder mentioned in their Keynotes
our approach to gen AI is comprehensive
you know so if you are a developer that
wants to play with the models or build a
custom model you can use Solutions like
vertex AI or model Garden to be able to
do that if you want to if you want
access to an AI platform where you can
you know do Chrome tuning do evals
you can do that with our AI platform
with ccai and similar Solutions what
we're really trying to do is
make all of that complexity simpler for
you and present it to you in a way that
makes sense for you so when it comes to
you know pricing it in a way that makes
sense for you or integrating it in a way
that makes sense for you or tuning these
AI models to make sure that they that
they address your use cases really
really well
I'm going to be talking more about sea
services and specifically about what are
the new things we are bringing
um to you when we're announcing today
which are powered by llms which really
Elevate the experience
and I wanted to play this video
just to give you a glimpse of that
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I know there's a lot in there but we're
going to sort of unpack that over the
course of this presentation and really
talk about what are the tools that we
are providing you to create an
experience like that
um so you know as I mentioned you know
virtual agents powered by dialogue flow
you know we dialogue for CX we really
provide you with a comprehensive Suite
through which to develop the virtual
agent experience you know when it comes
to handling detours
gracefully handling fallbacks
um you know with dollar for CX you can
handle all of that and do debugging
analytics and everything that comes with
it but really want to focus on today is
what are the new things that we are
bringing to the market
um and you know all these three are
initiatives that we've been working on
for a while powered by llm and
generative AI the first one is what we
call the generative AI agent
um which you know we also refer to it as
sometimes as infobots uh which is
basically
creating a virtual agent experience just
by linking a source of information
so you literally just link you know your
website FAQs uh to uh the virtual agent
and you can have a conversational AI
experience with it so it's literally at
the click of a button and what we've
seen in a lot of use cases where in the
past our customers would have translated
their existing business knowledge into
dialogflow CX graphs you don't need to
do that anymore you can just link those
documents and it's it works out of the
way
um and you know we're announcing this in
GA today this has already been in
production with multiple preview
customers I'm sure a lot of you have
probably had access to this as well
um and and I'm going to talk more about
later about how this is also powering
the agent facing experience and making
that better as well
the second key launch we have in virtual
agent is what we call generative
responses
so essentially uh today if you think
about it every single thing that your
virtual agent can say has to be written
in you know whatever virtual agent
solution you're using but with
generative AI we can actually help
generate those responses and we can do
that at the pace that you're comfortable
with so if you're comfortable the bot
speaking generator AI responses only in
case of a fallback you can set that as
well or for a given fulfillment you can
specify so you have full control over
when the generative part of the
responses take
the third key launch we have is what we
call generative flows which is launching
in preview today
which is basically saying that you can
write in natural language in English
what the bot is supposed to do and will
do that so for example if you have a use
case you know of menu ordering you know
I'm sure a lot of you have seen the
Wendy's Booth downstairs which is
exactly the same use case you can
literally mention the menu and say hey
virtual agent you're supposed to behave
like a very courteous uh you know agent
who can take orders from this menu you
can Define the person or the way you
want and we have templates for that and
that's it you don't have to go ahead and
create sort of thousands of intents and
pages and flows and go through all that
effort
and really the theme that we're trying
to hit on with this is the ultimate
agent the virtual agent that goes into
production is a much simpler graph than
what you're used to you know in the past
we have had you know some of our uh
Power users will create you know
thousands of intents and Pages because
they needed to do that you literally
needed to teach your virtual agent how
to speak English uh but now you can
really focus on the business rules and
on the content of what the agent is
supposed to talk about and not worry
about
um you know these scenarios which end up
sort of consuming a lot of your
development time and a lot of sort of
the agent size as well
the other thing I wanted to emphasize is
this comes as part of dialogue flow so
we know most of the people in this room
are already on a journey with dialogflow
you don't have to replace all of that
with this new experience you can start
augmenting uh your existing dialogflow
virtual agent with elements of
generative Ai and that's very important
because depending on the industry
depending on you know uh what kind of an
experience you want for your end users
your appetite for how generate how
generative the responses should be might
be very different and you get to decide
which elements of your virtual agent are
powered by these Technologies versus
which uh you know rely on the existing
dollar for CX technology
uh we're also announcing dialogue
so-called companion interview and and
it's you know what you saw in the video
with the multimedia input
um dollar for call Companion Powers it
which is basically while a voice call is
going on can we give an experience to
the end user where they have actually
have on their browser on their phone or
visual menu as well using which they
could navigate uh your ivrs
I wanted to spend some time on agent
assist so agent assist as I mentioned is
a suite of features
that we have to empower your agents to
make them more productive
we are announcing today two new features
knowledge assist which is uh launching
in preview
and as I mentioned it's you should think
of this as the generative AI agent or
the infobot for your live agent so you
know think of two scenarios your agent
is in a conversation with the end user
and they could they have an agent on
which they could search for answers
but we actually want to elevate that
experience and proactively provide
suggestions to the agent while the
conversation is going on so the agent
does not even need to search for it
based on the conversation that's going
on our generative AI knowledge assist
could tell them hey it seems the user is
asking about this this information
already exists in the documents here you
go and made that experience better for
them
next summarization
is such a key a key sort of end of call
activity that happens for some customers
literally at the end of each call we've
had customers who spend whose agents
spend 90 seconds at the end of the call
to summarize the conversation and you
know fill all of that information in the
system of record
we have been able to bring that time
down to near zero and llm generated
summary is better at compliance which
means every single call actually gets
summarized you know in with your live
agent sometimes they do not summarize
and you have all sorts of summaries in
different formats
um it's better of course at spelling and
making sure that it's it's actually you
know human readable and understandable
and and in terms of quality we have seen
the llm Baseline summarization to be you
know as good as the human summarization
and you know you don't have to create a
custom model you don't have to spend
three months trying to create something
which is only for yourself you can use
our LM summarization and get that job
done and something which has seen a lot
of success over the last few months as
organizations have started adopting
generative AI
CCI insights as I said tries to make
sense of conversational data that you
already have in your system the way we
do that is
is having annotations for this
conversational data so what are the key
topics being discussed in the
conversations what are the key questions
that the users are asking about you know
can we summarize the conversation and
insights itself how can we understand
what are the key words which matter to
you or key phrases and highlight that
for you
and what do we do with that we we create
custom metrics or aggregated metrics
depending on your use case so for
example if you have a quality management
use case where you want to create an
Asian level dashboard you can do that
with these metrics
um or you know you you want to really
understand what are the key topics for
virtual age and with our topic modeling
you can figure out which of the topics
which are being discussed and are simple
enough for the virtually you can design
your Asian training based on the
insights that you glean from this
we are announcing today generative fhu
as part of insights in preview
and what that does is really extract the
key questions from your conversation
so you want to understand hey I have you
know these millions of conversations
that flow through my system what are the
questions that our users are really
asking and is my FAQ is my agent
training is my virtual agent program
aligned with that or not and that has
been very meaningful for customers
because they're like oh I didn't even
realize that there are X number of
questions that our users are asking for
because I thought you know my FAQ was
robust and comprehensive or my agent
agent Pro training program was complete
and that's how uh generative FAQ is
really being used to to make it more
Dynamic instead of sort of once a year
or once or two year process of figuring
out what those FAQs would be
I want to spend some time talking about
CCI platform because as I said we've
been very excited about this program we
launched it last year and since then we
have had you know thousands of Agents
onboarded on CCI platform
um it has the message that we were
trying to convey to the industry has
resonated really really well with
customers and analysts
um so what we're really doing is as I
said bringing an AI first approach to
ccast instead of AI as an afterthought
we are trying to ensure that all of the
Gen AI llm driven capabilities that are
talked about are available on day one on
CCI platform so you know we have you
know you might have your contacts in the
provider taking whatever six months 12
months to integrate with Google but with
Google CCI you can just get it on day
one itself
um and it's it's also developed CCI
platform code develops these llm
capabilities along with the AI services
so that that integration itself is very
smooth and is not you know hacky or you
know just appears bolted on
we're also with CCR platform we were
also very keen on providing customers
with TurnKey Solutions which are
extendable so you know you you have a
lot of ccast cloud first layers in the
market should provide you tools but then
you need to create an entire Army of
developers uh you know working on it for
multiple months to spin up you know a
good experience for you with with CCI
platform you want to make sure that you
already have uh you know these TurnKey
Solutions or none key sort of templates
that could get you started on day one
itself
today we are announcing an Iva only
version of CCI platform we understand
you know that you know sometimes you
multi-year deals and getting out of
moving from an on-prem contact center to
a cloud contact center can be a
multi-year journey and we understand
that and that's why we created cpcci
platform IBA only option which gives you
a way to consume all of our gen AI
Services by having a light touch
pipeline going from your existing
contact center to Google CC Ai and you
know we can work with whatever
infrastructure you have and really give
you access to Genia Services
um as as soon as possible
we're also announcing
workforce management capabilities in CCI
platform today and and as I said our
idea with CCR platform is to be as
comprehensive as possible and our wfm
announcement is a key piece of that you
know when it comes to scheduling
forecasting adherence all the things I
can imagine in a wfm system all of that
comes native as part of CCI platform and
if you think about it
I talked about insights and trying to
glean metrics and annotations out of
each every single conversation now that
can actually feed into your wfo
Solutions and really make it more much
more powerful and much more Dynamic than
it used to be
again we work with your existing wfm and
qm providers as well we're announcing a
partnership with variant and alvaria
where if you have these Solutions CCI
platform can seamlessly integrate with
that
so I'm now going to hand it over to mina
who's our GTM lead who's going to talk
more about how we are bringing these
solutions to market for you thank you
good morning everybody
[Music]
generic conversation is always very dear
to me guess what in 2020 the element
model we were building at Google was
also called Mina
so I want to start off by taking you all
back in time a few years ago we had a
dream a dream to transform the contacts
into space
and in this dream we envisioned
personalized predictive and memorable
conversations elevating the self-service
space
we thought about very happy super
productive human agents loving what they
do right and being powered and coached
by AI models on the Fly
the envisioned business intelligence as
well as insights being actionable and
being offered to contact center leaders
to make the toughest business decisions
and we wanted to orchestrate all of this
via a ccas platform that's designed for
scale so security and speed now as you
all are aware as we heard from shantanu
we've had this life for a while now
but this Vision got even grander because
ccai is going to be the launch vehicle
to bring enterprise-ready generative AI
superpowering customer experiences
so how do we make this real for you
so our focus is on choice and
flexibility one you get to use the
entire platform right with its full
end-to-end offerings or two you get to
consume the latest and greatest of
generative AI we are your Partnerships
with oems or thirdly as shantana just
announced you can use the CCI platform
as a lightweight conduit powering the
latest and greatest of generative AI on
your legacy infrastructure
so with this choice and flexibility in
mind here is how a transformation
Journey could look like
with our resilient focus on time to
Market we have come up with three value
packages
so from day one to four weeks you can
get info Bots powered by generative AI
up and running you can have agent
summarizations enabled just like the
demo that you saw around simple bikes
and you can have insights topic modeling
up and running giving you insights into
your call drivers and intense so that's
week four from week four to week 12
could be a great time to get chat
invoice enabled for agent assist as well
as start you know augmenting and
potentially replacing some of your
speech applications
thirdly as you enter into month three
and onwards this is the time for you to
bring in all of those transactional
intents as well as leverage customer MLM
modeling for your unique business cases
so a transformation Journey like this
between day 0 to about three months and
onwards can only be enabled when we have
a large partner ecosystem
so I'm super excited to share with you
all that we have over 50 partners and
several thousands of subject matter
experts who are trained to deliver the
ccai Journeys For You at scale
with our partner ecosystem what they
come with is a very deep industry
expertise the operational know-how and
most importantly the niche with respect
to contact center skill sets right so
with all the latest and greatest of
generative AI as well as having partners
with the know how to implement the
journey for you
what do you think success would look
like
so
it's really the right time now to Pivot
into two very important customer
Journeys here these are stories of
innovation
Excellence as well as inspiration
starting their Journey on dialogue flow
es automating chat conversations and
then expanding that to dialogflow CX
focusing on the multi-language support
the Omni Channel capabilities and
finally landing on the ccai platform
solving for the focus areas of
innovation scale speed and security I'm
extremely honored to welcome Alex Tran
onto the stage as he's going to share
the Gen digital T-Tech and Google Better
Together story welcome Alex
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hi
my name is Alex Tran I am
responsible for product development at a
product Builder operations at gen
we within the consumer support and
insight sales organization
Jen's portfolio includes Norden
Avast
LifeLock
Avira ABG reputation Defender and
CCleaner
our family of trusted consumer brands
protects nearly 500 million consumers
worldwide
gen ambition is to create Technology
Solutions for people and to to in order
to make the most of the digital world
safely privately and confidential
to to deliver
excellent customer experience and agent
must be equipped with the right tools
and train to use the tools efficiently
we needed to consolidate
our multi multiple telephony systems
carriers
crms
chat systems workforce management
contact flows and AI automation across
all of our brands
we recently Consolidated onto a contact
solution to Google's contact center AI
platform
and so so why did we choose Google
at gen we believe that AI Services apply
to
the contact center space
on an end-to-end platform would dominate
customer service
we will believe that that would
transform the customer and agent
experience
and LeapFrog the industry
Jen needed
a solution that supported
integrated AI
a real-time machine translation language
translator
across all channels including voice
we wanted a bring your own carrier
solution that needed our business needs
stability security
speed of deployment
a a conversation engine that can be
scaled across all channels
and finally an AI solution that could
keep up with the rapid Innovation
partner up with a leader in this space
so how did the implementation go
you know we have over 7 000 phone
numbers domestic and international
300 plus call flows
2 000 plus agents
multiple carriers
10 plus delivery locations
oh sorry about that I forgot
introduction uh
10 plus delivery locations and 21
languages
across all of our brands we have
experience for multiple telephony chat
and CRM providers
we we have experience from every type of
contact center environment
on premise
infrastructure to service platform as a
service software as a service we try
them all
based on our experience the time that it
takes to migrate one just one single
voice platform
takes anywhere between seven months to
one year and that's provided that you
have a seasoned crew that that this crew
owns product development operations and
infrastructure and development
with ccip
we deliver not only one
but two celebrity migration
in four and a half months
so basically we received our environment
freshly formatted
in mid-april and that's this mid-april
of 2023
we and we started the row out to all of
our contact centers beginning of August
and we completed the last one last night
uh so with so with previous migrations
this would have taken
approximately two years
so one of our our key business kpis
are service level average handle time Q
time wait time calls handle
we were able to reach stability
within the first one to two weeks pretty
amazing
and and this is really a a a phenomenal
indication that you know our agents are
trained they're familiar with the youth
the new UI
they understand the new processes uh we
have our agent profile profiles
correctly configured and migrated and we
have called sprouted into the right cues
so how will we even accomplish this feat
so we partnered with T-Tech a premier
system integrator for Google
and and T-Tech
has their own contact center BPO
business
that is currently also adopting Google
ccip
so they have to get this right
okay
um our partnership with Google
gave us an opportunity to adjust
priorities
of the the critical features that we
needed at gen
there were some gaps
that there was absence of Gap but a bit
heroin and the product team at Google
did as a solid
we were able to influence the roadmap
and quickly close the gaps and meet our
timelines
so additionally we're also in the
process of looping chat which we
estimated we completed in three to four
months which is another record for us
so so what's so what's for the impact to
our business
well we realize our Synergy goals
a reduction in platform and
infrastructure costs
uh Google's Voice network architecture
gives you the ability to Ingress
the customer call
at the closest point to the customer
send it over Google's high-speed Network
and egress
to call to the to the to the closest to
the agent's client
and what that resulted it
it's outstanding
High Fidelity
audio without the need for costly mpos
Networks
we have a single
pricing licensing motto
for all of our channels so whether it's
voice chat SMS email messenger social
this allows us to engage our customer on
the channel that works best for them
and we have the ability to scale our
licensing
or down based on seasonal traffic
so we so we started our journey with
dollar flow in 2018
right as it is what ga
and we needed a conversation engine that
was portable
we didn't we didn't want to be in a
position where we where we had to
rebuild all of our automation
and from scratch and since and since we
transitioned the dialogue flow we
migrated our chat platforms three times
and in every instances we did not need
to redo our automation
we we get about 30 containment from
voice and 40 percent from chat
so the Google SAS model gives us ability
to try out new features without all the
upfront investment and commitments
looker bigquery
vertex AI agent assists
speech to text sentiment
this this one
so
what's next
what is the future what what's in store
for gender in the future
so there's been a lot of conversation at
this conference about vertex AI
for Jen we are interested in AI
to assist our customers
and our agents
so at the end of every contact agents
spends several minutes to summarize the
case and to classify the type of call
operationally we want to get to a
granular case type
but what we found out is that the longer
the list we make the agents just choose
the first option from the list
so
we believe that we can leverage vertex
Ai and agent assist to significantly
reduce the time that it takes to
summarize and classify the case
we want to enable our agents with AI
power conversations for for all of our
voice and digital channels
to provide our 500 million customers
with a personalized experience we need
the one we need to pay we need to
identify the customer
two we need to disposition their needs
and three we need to Route the
appropriate so we need to Route them to
appropriate queue whether it's self-help
or to an agent
AI routing will be a big part of the
customer Journey
we want to use AI recommendation for
cross sales and upsells
we want to leverage Google dialogflow's
native integration with generative AI
so when we're unable to detect a
customer's intent we we can fall back on
genitive AI to provide the knowledge
there there are times there are times
where you can where you need to have
both a directive conversation like
performing a multi-step transaction
we need the ability to switch between
directive
and a generative conversation and dollar
Globe makes that integration seamless
Google is one of two solutions
that have complete vertical integration
and it's at the Forefront of AI
we plan to take full use of Google's
innovation
now that our contact center is platform
is tightly coupled with the Google
technology stack
that includes Google Cloud
looker insights bigquery vertex Ai and
dialog flow
so I I would like to thank the team an
entire gen consumer support organization
and inside sales organization my team T
Tech and Google for the teamwork that
realize our vision uh and if anyone else
tells you you cannot transform your
contact center platform quickly give me
a call
all right thank you for your time
thank you
CTO of
[Applause]
thanks Alex
um one of the advantages of going last
is like I get to say the final words but
also feels very familiar to the world we
live in uh three minutes faster delivery
um very much summarizes what we went
through so I'll quickly go through our
digital transformation that was
primarily enabled through dialogue flow
and the contact center technologies that
Google offers
one of the big challenge is
traditionally every bank is looked at as
slow pace change and Wells Fargo is a
173 year old bank so we were looking at
not just accelerating but leapfrogging
to more modern experiences to keep up
with our customer experiences because we
are holding ourselves to higher
standards from a digital experience
standpoint uh and want to have a digital
parity of providing a similar familiar
experience to the best digital
experience the customer prior to your
landing on the Wells Fargo mobile app
with that we started off with like some
founding principles around making it
simplified personalized and insightful
and as we went through this journey we
partnered with Google as a part of our
strategic partnership
um it was publicly announced that we uh
we are partnering with Google to
transform our entire infrastructure and
move our strategic AI assets and data
assets into the Google Cloud
and one of the first uh use case that we
started off was the most complex one
um which was Fargo and I'll quickly like
run through some of the things that
Fargo can do and
as as it plays there's no music but I'll
try to talk to
Fargo is our virtual assistant that was
launched about uh
uh four months ago in partnership with
Google behind the scenes there's the
dialogflow agent
but the whole idea was to make the
entire mobile interactions through our
app very familiar uh little less Bank
speak but very natural
and with few tenants that are you know
highly engaging from a customer
standpoint so for example if you had to
look up your Financial Health
uh or get to the transactions faster
which by the way is the most used
feature on our app today
um and also any of these steps that you
could imagine with any of your you know
banking app that you use these tend to
be multi-step uh and we are trying to
reduce that amount of time you spend in
you know
living in a banking World nobody wakes
up in the morning saying Hey I want to
do banking we want to kind of take that
friction away
and most importantly we also want to get
to personal insights uh or repeat of
them this is not the ccai insights
that's for different operators this is
for the users
so
um bottom line I think you know we've
launched this and we you know everybody
here uh we've had several Partners from
Google and the whole ecosystem of teams
it definitely does take a village
um to get something out there and this
also happens to be our first
uh use case on our Google Cloud virtual
private Cloud that we had started off so
many learnings many takeaways
and in terms of the Fargo Evolution
itself one of the things that connects
back to everything shantini was talking
about in how we look at evolving the
experience but also tying back to every
technology
enhancement that is happening
what we would uh take this forward is
from an assistant to an advisor kind of
an experience where over a period of
time these are done for the customers as
opposed to them wanting to go into an
app and spending time uh some time doing
this activities
just to quickly go through uh this is
kind of our high level blueprint and
where dialogflow sits today
we were very intentional in how we built
this one out unlike the contact center
experiences this is a digital and a
mobile experience and we modulized every
building block uh with some founding
principles around Security First
resiliency
and as you can imagine from a mobile
standpoint the number one uh adoption
Factor would be the response times so we
had to make sure that the entire
platform was extremely resilient and had
extremely fast response times as well
and since this was our first array into
a going out of our data centers into a
Google data center it wasn't fun but we
had a lot of learnings from that
okay
um that's all my with my time but one
takeaway if you're if you're a Wells
Fargo customer and if you have not
already engaged with Fargo please
download the app please go to Fargo uh
provide your feedback and connecting
back to shantanu this is just the
Journey of where we are uh and we are
closely partnering with Google Around
The Trusted tested program uh to
constantly look at where we can plug in
all the New Gen AI capabilities into our
product thank you
foreign